des problèmes juridiques qui se posent
en matière d'évolution de la loi sur ces
deux points aussi bien pour l'euthanasie
que pour le suicide assisté sont
considérables pour l'euthanasie c'est
évident on le fait d'administrer la mort
et considéré dans notre code pénal comme
un assassinat même si la personne
d'ailleurs est consentante puisque ça ne
ça ne consiste pas ça ne constitue pas
un fait justificatif
par ailleurs
les les fondements donc de notre compte
pénal mais également les principaux
fondamentaux sur lesquels ce code est
établi à savoir la prohibition de tuer
qui n'est pas simplement bon évidemment
on peut on ne peut pas ne pas leur
apporter un héritage religieux mais mais
la plupart mais l'essentiel de nos
systèmes normatifs et est issu de
prescriptions religieuses qui dans ce
cas sont totalement laïcisés il reste
que la prohibition de tuer est au
fondement de la notion d'intégrité
personnelle et de respect de la personne
humaine qui est au cœur de notre
conception libérale je ne peux pas
imaginer une société libre qui apporte
la moindre nuance à ce principe qui est
un principe absolu et fondamental de
l'intégrité humaine
et par ailleurs
le fait que
est reconnu une sorte de l'importance
que nos sociétés accorde consentement et
à l'expression
ultime de la volonté est aussi un
principe fondamental que l'euthanasie à
première vue tel que je l'ai décrite
lorsqu'il s'agit d'administrer la mort à
une principe à une personne inconsciente
peu bafouer alors les choses ne sont pas
très ne sont pas si simple que ça pour
les suicides insister non plus puisque
le fait de procurer une personne les
moyens de mettre fin à ses jours
et l'objet d'une jurisprudence qui tente
à considérer cela comme un crime
incontestablement et par ailleurs le
fait de ne pas empêcher une personne de
se servir des moyens de mettre fin à ce
jour est un cas caractérisé de
non-assistance à personne en danger mais
au moins dans le cas de l'assistance au
suicide est préservé cette souveraineté
de la volonté de la personne sur ce
qu'elle fait de sa vie et cette comme je
l'ai dit c'est ultime espace de liberté
qui lui est laissé au moment au dernier
moment de se servir de ses moyens ou de
ne pas s'en servir
j'insiste sur le point que dans ce que
je viens de dire ce qui peut amener une
personne a décidé
étant donné ce qu'est sa situation
médicale étant donné qu'elle n'a aucune
espérance de survie ou de là de quelques
mois ce qui peut la décider à vouloir
être fin à ses jours n'appartient qu'à
elle de ne peut pas être jugé je ne vais
pas prononcé le moindre jugement moral
là-dessus ça a trait à la sphère la plus
intime la plus personnelle des
engagements de la personne
mais en revanche il me paraît que
préserver l'intégrité de ce moment de
choix ultime est une chose tout à fait
essentielle dont nous sommes
collectivement responsables dans nos
sociétés sont responsables
or elle me semble cette ce principe là
me semble en partie
me sembleront en partie violée par une
loi à propos de l'euthanasie